j'ai été formé à quelque chose
je n'ai aucune cause à des ford fn 21 87
voici comment s'appelait le second
protagoniste principal du nouveau star
wars devenu fine avant qu'il ne
désertent le premier ordre joué par john
boyega fine est un externe trooper élevé
depuis la naissance pour devenir un
soldat servant le premier ordre
il n'hésita pas à déserter celui ci
après sa première mission en sauvant le
célèbre pilote résistants peau d'âme ron
accompagnant ray tout le long de
l'aventuré son passé n'est pas évoqué
une seule fois durant le film et peut
nous laisser donc supposer d'où
viendrait ce jeune protagoniste
je vous propose donc trois théories qui
me semblent intéressantes
bon jeu là vous le fait qu'il ait une
peau de couleur nous guide un petit peu
dans nos théories m wind ou anciens
maîtres jedi tué de la main de
l'empereur sidious et d'anakin skywalker
pourrait avoir un lien de parenté avec
notre jeune résistant
cette théorie a même été envisagée par
l'acteur john boyega cité il y un
instant qui joue fine peut-être une
piste fine se débrouiller un tout petit
peu avec le sabre laser
cependant on sent qu'il ne sait pas se
servir de la force mais peut-être qu'il
se défend plutôt bien car il a un lien
de parenté avec wind ou cependant m
windu êtes un senior chez les jedi il
les dirigeait avec ce bon vieux maître
yoda la règle stipule bien que les jedi
n'ont pas le droit d'avoir de relation
je doute qu'un senior jedi comme wind ou
est en france cette règle de plus m
windu est mort lors de l'épisode 3 de la
saga star wars soit environ 60 à 70 ans
avant star wars sept ont ça voudrait
dire que finn serait le petit fils ou
l'arrière petit fils dans ce cas non
cette théorie ne fonctionne pas pour moi
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire théorie numéro 2
cette théorie me plaît beaucoup et je
l'avais déjà imaginé avec mon père après
avoir vu le film
lando calrissian interprété par billy
dee williams est un personnage
secondaire de la seconde trilogie est un
très vieil ami de han solo depuis le cp
certainement contrebandiers il est le
précédent propriétaire du faucon
millenium sous le chantage du seigneur
vador
il est contraint de l'aider à piéger en
solo et la princesse leia en échange
d'une promesse de lempire de ne pas
s'occuper de ses affaires plus ou moins
légales cependant étant duper par vador
il aidera les ja à s'échapper et
rejoindra l'alliance rebelle par la
suite où il sera nommé laideur or enfin
bref landau est toujours vivant à la fin
de star wars 6 après que l'empereur et
dark vador soit vaincu donc cette
théorie est déjà plus plausible de plus
lent ne donna rien à voir avec la force
et jedi même si le comité est finie il
peut donc avoir des relations
ensuite depuis star wars 7 les stands
trooper ne sont plus des clones mais des
enfants arrachés dès la naissance et par
la suite entraîné pour un seul but
devenir soldat du premier ordre
finn affirmant ne pas connaître ses
parents auraient pu être arrachée à
landeleau dès sa naissance et devenir un
stormtrooper au service du premier ordre
j'en conviens que la couleur de peau
nous influencent beaucoup aussi
cependant cette théorie est totalement
plausible pour moi et ça ne m'étonnerait
pas que feeling soit le fils de lando
calrissian je pense qu'il est évident
que nous aurons toutes les réponses dans
les prochains opus je ne me pencherai
pas sur la théorie que fit une soul fils
de lando et les ja car elle met
invraisemblable je ne pense pas du tout
que l'eia et trompait and avec le dos et
un enfant avec celui ci en plus à part
peut-être par vengeance mais vous
comprendrez mieux avec la troisième
théorie
cette théorie peut sembler improbable
néanmoins elle est tout aussi plausible
que la précédente
durant la première trilogie saviez vous
que le légendaire contrebandiers en solo
était mariée avant de connaître les gars
tout particulièrement dans l'épisode 4
c'est à dire le tout premier épisode de
la saga star wars soit lorsqu'il fit la
connaissance de luke leia et obi wan
cependant cette théorie est inspiré des
comics mais disney a prétendu qu'il
pourrait s'inspirer peut-être de la
bande dessinée mais la question est qui
était la personne avec qui anne aurait
pu se marier
il s'agit de sanaa solo de son vrai nom
sanaa staros c'est une femme qui en
comptera en solo durant la guerre civile
galactique
elle prétend être la femme de han solo
cependant celui-ci a toujours nié être
marié à sanaa néanmoins tout le monde
connaît la réputation du contrebandier
sachant très bien mentir c'est ce
qu'elle confirme à quand il nya leur
relation qu'il n'était doué que pour le
mensonge
d'après mes sources à l'époque anne solo
finissait par trouver ça n'a comme une
femme dangereuse à son égard et essayait
alors de l'éviter le stockage commence
donc ici sanaa affirmant crâne solo lui
appartenait ce mis à sa recherche
elle était même prête à tuer n'importe
qui pour le retrouver elle finit
finalement par retrouver en solo en
compagnie de l'eia la date précise se
situerait entre l'épisode iv un nouvel
espoir et l'épisode 5 l'empiré contre
attaque soit après la destruction de la
première étoile de la mort
elle arriva en affirmant qu'ils mentent
et et qu'elle le savait bien car son nom
était sanaa solo et quelle était sa
femme
l'eia rétorqua alors que ce n'était pas
ses histoires et décida de laisser
tomber en solo qui lui demandait de
rester cela expliquerait pourquoi la
romance entre lui et les ja apparu
tardivement dans la première trilogie à
cause de sanaa staros peu de personnes
apprécient cette théorie car le
personnage de sanaa a paru le 3 juin
2015 dans les comics marvel ce qui est
très récent
ce personnage sort de nulle part et
débarque en affirmant être la femme de
en solo c'est vrai que ça fait un peu
gros pourtant elle pourrait bien devenir
un personnage récurrent de la série et
disney et le cas ce film pourrait
peut-être l'utiliser pour les prochains
films
après tout ce ne pourrait bien n'être
fortement d'harceler glisse l'ancien
maître de dark sidious ce personnage
provient aussi des livres mais nous en
reparlerons dans une prochaine vidéo
fine pourrait donc bien avoir un lien de
parenté avec cette prétendue madame solo
cependant une fois de plus l'écart est
beaucoup trop grand car fina que 23 ans
et star wars cats se situe à plus de 40
ans de star wars 7
serait ce donc le petit-fils de sanaa et
anne dans ce cas je trouve ça un petit
peu trop tiré par les cheveux
néanmoins je vous rappelle que star wars
7 est un calque de la première trilogie
et que luke et leia paraissait un petit
peu pour deux amants et qui finalement
se sont avérés être des frères et soeurs
il se pourrait que ça soit le cas pour
ré et fines qui sont des amis plutôt
proches à la fin du film mais qui
finalement aurait tous deux un lien de
parenté les unissant qu'en pensez vous
n'hésitez pas à me dire ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires
votre avis mais important et n'hésitez
pas à proposer d'autres théories
l'espace commentaires est là pour ça
pensez au pouce bleus qui soutient
énormément cette émission et qui me
récompense et merci aux plus sages
d'entre vous qui auront partagé la vidéo
à leurs amis les plus proches que le
'lion' alors soit avec vous cet art rock
à bientôt